[Music]
christians with us in san jose hi
christian welcome to the ramsey show
hello mr ramsay hello mr camel how you
guys doing great man what's up
hey so my question is whether or not i
should sell my home uh with my wife and
um
either rent something out or uh buy a
new home
okay why would you do that
um so right now we live in hollister
california um our commute is about an
hour
um when we do commute uh usually we just
stay with my mother-in-law
so we're rarely ever at home
okay well it does sound like a move is
in order in the direction of your work
what do you make of your household
income
uh together we make approximately 180 to
200 000 a year cool that's good news
well you live in a super expensive area
so i was hoping you made some money
um
yeah so if you sell and re-buy in the
other area that's closer does that work
the thing is right now our current home
we owe 545 000
it's
approximately 100 or 830 000
is what it's worth
but everything we're looking for in san
jose california is approximately 1.2
million yeah i bet
uh great news is you make 180 right
yes sir yeah so what i would do uh is
quit looking at 1.2 i mean that that may
be the worst house in san jose it's
possible that's a super high area uh but
the uh but i'm gonna really try to find
the house that's even worse than that
that you're just really ashamed of and
hate in and at least make your move and
get your life back on the commute
and then start saving like crazy and
move up into a little better house in
that same community then
but i'm not you know all of this
together does not equal buy something
you can't afford and beats the crap out
of you with the monthly payment and
you're sitting in the corner sucking
your thumb because your house poor
nothing is worth that i understand yeah
don't do that so can you split the
difference and maybe you live 20 minutes
out from san jose and you can find a
place that's
you know eight hundred thousand it's 700
now 20 minutes out is what he's talking
about i mean it's it's it's that's just
you're just dealing with silicon valley
man i mean it's just unbelievable yeah
it's gross
i mean it it it's it's a ridiculous
world when you make 180 000 and can't
live and that's a lot that's a crazy
word but it is the world you're in dude
i mean it's
uh i mean
you got kids yeah i mean it's just i i
think you i think you start trying to
make the move but you just make it super
conservative
and
uncomfortable you're gonna choose your
discomfort yeah
choose the our commute
or a house that sucks
as a stepping stone to a house that
doesn't suck and that you build up with
you because your income you're young
enough your incomes are going to
continue to go up
you're in that market and man that's
tough because even with you know 280
down on the new one on a 1.2 you're
looking at an astronomical monthly
payment oh yeah yeah even making it
interesting it's just it's just hard
but that's you don't get passed on math
you can't
you got to have the income to do the
deal
regardless you don't get a pass just
because i chose to live there it means
you can't live there or whatever so it's
um when i was growing up we lived
across the tracks on the other side of
the tracks over here literally i mean
behind me there's some tracks and so
one county over from here and this
county that we're in is a very wealthy
county
and uh we used to talk about the rich
people that lived over here and we went
you can't live over there you know we we
couldn't afford to live over here we
weren't bad people but we weren't poor
people we just couldn't afford to live
over here yeah it's expensive
and so that's just what you're facing i
mean sometimes you look across the
tracks and you just can't afford to live
over there
and until your income changes or
something else got to adjust your
expectations it's hard to do that's hard